During the 13th century, cathedrals sprang up all over Europe.
By the 14th century, it was universities, most of them built just after the death of Marco Polo.
1343 Pisa, 1347 Prague, Pavia, Warsaw, Vienna, Erfurt, Heidelberg, Cologne, Bologna, 1088, Paris, 1120, Toulouse, Naples, Salamanca, and Lisbon.
Hopes fled Rome and settled in Avignon, France.
Harvests were abundant, but Europe's population soon tripled, then quadrupled, until her population reached 100 million.
The result? Shortages of everything.
In 1315, a widespread famine caused indescribable misery.
But worse still was the Black Plague, brought in by a Genoese ship from the Crimea in 1348.
The bubonic, or Black Plague, contagious in the extreme.
This is the fault of the Jews.
Caminated our food.
Their poisoning of the wells.
Death to the Jews.
Excommunicate all those who dare harm these innocent people.
But no one was listening. Nearly a thousand died each day in Avignon alone.
Three months, half the city lay dead.
In three years, Europe lost 25 million people, one quarter of her population.
All this did not prevent the Hundred Years' War from continuing.
Crecy, France, where the impetuous French cavalry under Philippe of Valois nearly trampled their own foot soldiers during the charge,
only to be given a thrashing by the enemy which was on foot.
Battle upon battle, and no one learned from his defeats.
In 1356, Poitiers, the Battle of Crecy all over again.
Even the papacy split in two.
Urban VI was in Rome and Clement VII in Avignon.
Not only did they disagree, they disagreed violently.
France, Castile, Aragon, Naples, and Scotland were Clement's territory.
Northern Italy, Germany, England, Scandinavia, Poland, and Hungary were reserved for urban.
At Oxford, a priest and theologian named Wycliffe denounced the two popes for squabbling over the throne like dogs over a bone.
He also denounced the sale of posts within the church.
The Archbishop of Canterbury lost no time in excommunicating him.
It was John Ball, a priest, who took Wycliffe's place.
When they dress in velvet, drink fine wines, and set their tables with spices and white bread,
while we eat brides, sleep on straw.
While they lead idle lives in their manners, we toil and sweat.
John Ball ended up in prison.
Bragg's university had a rector called John Huss.
For him, the word of God was all-important,
and anything else was pagan.
Only Satan's henchmen would dare make use of the church
to fill his belly, dress richly, and move up in the world.
The Roman pope relieved the revolutionary Huss of his priesthood.
That fellow's a real nuisance in sex communication!
A council was called in Pisa.
Its purpose, end the schism.
Method, by naming a new pope for a grand total of three.
The excommunicated John Huss appeared at the Council of Constance at the request of his emperor, Sigismund of Luxembourg, who provided him with a safe conduct.
Before the learned assembly, Huss was arrested. The emperor didn't lift a finger. Instead, Huss was tried and condemned.
The death of Huss enraged the people and triggered a general uprising against the Germans.
Avenge Huss! Avenge Huss! Avenge Huss! Avenge Huss!
The church was unable to patch things up in time. A rupture in Catholic unity was imminent.
And the same year John Huss was burned at the stake, yet another disaster in the crazy and poachy tradition, Agincourt.
Watch out, Lurch!
Hey, all right, pal.
Uh-huh.
Yes.
What do we do now?
Better get going.
Can't hang around here.
Come on.
Okay.
Let's go.
I got you off already.
Yeah?
I'm starting to get hungry.
Oh.
Let's get out of here.
Be a purse now.
Oh, mercy, spare us.
Please don't harm us.
Okay.
The way they hand me!
Safe!
You're most grateful!
Thank you!
Wait, take it!
What's this?
Well, what next?
Well, what do you know?
Here's what has to be done. Not so bad after all.
Sure, it's easier than walking.
Walk!
What do you do about this?
See what's going on inside.
Alright, show me the loot.
speak for the last time. Show me the dough. Speak up. Yeah. Excellent. Excellent. Strangers,
why don't you stay on here with us? We'll treat you well. I'm getting old, my son. Seems to me
you'd make an able blacksmith. Be my helper. The big one's nicer. Well, we accept, sir.
Oh, that's wonderful. That's wonderful. Farewell, William. Stay back now. Take good care, boy.
While Burgundians and Armagnacs were busy killing one another, the English calmly went on with their
conquest of France. The Dauphin Charles went into hiding at Bouge. His right to the throne was
attacked most viciously by Isabella of Bavaria, his own mother. Teach you how to hunt in the woods.
Try it. You'll really like it. Your life's much more peaceful in the city. There they are. Look at all
William. Carpets. At my prices, it's a giveaway. I'll try my fine candles or them healing herbs,
portions. How about a necklace? And for you, Mrs., I've set aside this lovely length of cloth. It's
quite a deal, believe me. Oh, William, it's much too much. No? I'm letting you have it for nothing,
you know here a good pal it's less for pals so long everybody so long bye-bye take that my very
latest invention to cut off my beard which is cutting this other invention go on don't worry
it works and here's my next invention a pendulum with weights works like a clock when do you see
this secular chickens come and choose find up the LA's best apples you've ever seen don't you
And believe you me, they're guaranteed worm-free.
Recession in honor of their patron saints in Crispin, business sure is booming in the city.
Farewell, friends, farewell.
The gentleman's back.
Look, smoked herring.
Tell me how you like it.
Are we supposed to eat these things?
I never...
Oh, it's very cute.
That's just girl stuff again.
Yeah.
You're so smart, idiots.
Just come over here.
Listen to this.
it's hardly believable now listen no one will believe this it seems that a young shepherdess
rode on horseback to the dauphin's castle at chinon to trick her the prince hid among his
courtiers and put a richly dressed young noble on the throne instead but the shepherdess went
straight to the dauphin kneeled before him and told him her mission to see him crown king he was
so impressed he gave her an army and his bravest armagnac captains let's go give her a hat so he's
We've got our way to the besieged city of Orléans right now.
We've sworn to free the city.
Well, then we're leaving.
Don't worry, you know we always come out on top of these things.
Well...
The boys have grown up now. They'll be able to help you.
Couldn't just abandon that poor little girl, could we? Could we?
Among those defending the besieged city of Orléans, morale was at its lowest point.
Suddenly, Joan broke through the English lines, and she and her men entered the captive city,
During an assault on an enemy fortress, and off we go towards the Reims Cathedral, where Charles VII takes his divine place as King of France.
Aside, whether it's from there, kind of pinch him in like, hey.
Brilliant point, chief.
What a nice banner you have.
Good day, Bert. Hello, William.
Machine. Ha ha.
Don't miss him.
Anything you can leave.
And set everything on fire.
One of these days.
The scaffolding will get some wood from the Lord.
He won't give up any of his wood.
Yes, he will. Isn't he our protector?
Well, I can guarantee you'll listen.
Due to your poor protection, my lord, you are responsible for damages.
Now, for rebuilding our homes, we'll donate our labor and you, your wood.
My word, absolutely out of the question.
Careful now, my lord. Give it some thought now.
Fine, perfect. It'll cost you 50 pounds.
But that's far too much. That's way beyond our means.
Wait for me. I've got an idea.
Good sir, could you do us a favor?
Why, sure.
Ah, I'm missing some, too, to be exact.
Huh?
What?
Stop, stop, stop!
You go.
Very good.
Shaping up again, huh?
Gotta be.
You wait, you!
Friends, worn out and discouraged, decide to come back to the city walls for shelter.
Life will be safer here.
Hey, hey, wait for me! Come on, wake up!
Rather see the procession on St. Etienne's.
If you take my advice, it's always St. Honoré's it's best.
It's time!
Good day.
Oh!
So long, friends.
So long, William.
You're most kind. God will reward you.
Thank you. Most kind of you.
Most kind will reward you.
Answer me? But where's the staircase?
It was on the plans.
Hold on, we'll take care of that. You don't say.
There, that'll be better. Goes up, comes down.
I want a stairway. Nothing else.
All right, you'll stick in the mud. Fuddy-duddy.
Lopsided. It's lopsided.
and it works oh come over here isn't that better a wind-up clock take a look the mechanism like it
missing gone wrong throw this out the window now this time i have an idea perfect excellent
couldn't be better now we'll just take a wine press and we'll make an imprint of these letters
on a piece of paper the results are to be very interesting ah no more need for copying books by
Very nice.
That's a good idea.
Everyone.
Welcome, traveler.
I have some sad news, friends.
Joan of Arc has been burned at Rouen.
At long last, the Hundred Years' War did end in a shambles.
In Paris, 24,000 homes went to ruin.
Limoges had five townsmen left.
Wolves roamed everywhere, and cities ravaged by battles and the plague.
In 1453, Gutenberg printed the first Bible.
In the same year, in Constantinople, Justinian's ramparts gave way to the Turks.
Byzantine artists fled to Italy and would help create the Renaissance.
And at Vinci, a town near Florence, a baby named Leonardo was already thinking inventive thoughts.